Labour's next leader will be chosen by
its half a million or so members in the
coming months Sky News has the result of
the very first poll of labour members
asking who they want to succeed Jeremy
Corbyn on behalf of the party members
project for the economic Social Research
Council run out of Queen Mary and Sussex
University's YouGov polled 1059 labour
members here's who they put down as
their first preference Shadow brexit
secretary Kirsten
comes out on top getting 31% of first
preferences korbinite favorite and
shadow business secretary Rebecca long
Bailey comes out second on 20% and the
rest trail those two when it comes to
voting labour runs a preferential system
meaning that members are asked to rank
who they want in numerical order if no
one gets over 50% then one candidate is
knocked out in each round and the votes
of the eliminated candidate
redistributed amongst the others so
using this method who does that suggest
the poll thinks will win in the opening
round
Leeson andis knocked out then in round 2
Emily Thornbury then in round 3 clive
Lewis and in round 4 Yvette Cooper Jess
Phillips is out in round five that
leaves just two contenders going
head-to-head in the final round here
Kirsten has a 22 point lead over his
rival giving him a comfortable victory
if this poll was replicated on Election
Day
kiss stahma beats Rebecca long Bailey in
every age category in every region
amongst men and women and amongst them
professional classes and the working
class is the only group that who favor
long Bailey over stommer
our labour members who voted to leave
the EU in 2016 remain as back stommer
now there are plenty of caveats when it
comes to working out Jeremy Corbyn
successor a pole isn't a prediction some
candidates may yet into the race or pull
out and it might not include some of the
other categories of supporter who turned
out to be eligible to vote but on the
basis of this early Peck polling
exercise it seems Jeremy Corbyn and his
team won the hearts of party members in
2015 but not the right to determine its
future direction in 2019